shamsher Anya the great NBA insider for
the athletic he was the first to break
the rudy gobert testing positive for
coronavirus also Kevin Durant Christian
would too Laker players have all tested
positive and Tom's was the leading man
on those stories as well when do you
think we'll find out the Laker players
who tested positive
yeah damn great join you um no I think
it's reached a point where it's really
on the players to come forward or you
know obviously my job as a reporter is
to you know probe and see but it's
reached a level where I think there are
two spectrums you know I think there's
one side of players that want to raise
awareness and you know want want to you
know make things you know I guess have
their voice on it and really want to
remind America and the public in terms
of just like staying quarantine staying
safe being careful I think there is
still that stigma around it for another
sector of players and people and so
that's just something that everyone has
to deal with I'm not sure when those
will be out there I don't know who those
two players are right now and but really
it doesn't matter just the fact that you
know you've had I think five six seven
eight organization more than a handful
of organizations now impacted by the
corona virus and the whole league hasn't
even been tested yet and I think that
just goes to show you kind of what's
going on around the country in terms of
there's a monitor there's an amount of
cases right now that we know of but I'm
sure there are plenty more what do you
think the likelihood is of basketball
returning this year I wish I could tell
you it's very likely I I don't know I
think you're really looking at playing
from anywhere between June and August I
think that that's where players and
teams and owners and even the league
office have essentially targeted those
kinds of three month period you know
they had dr. Vivek Murthy on the Board
of Governors call I was told earlier
this week and he looked you know all the
owners know kind of gave them some
sobering facts in terms this is going to
reach an inflection point over the next
two to three months across the country
and even in the NBA the cases will rise
and the comparison that Italy was made
and so I think there's
there's a soberness to that and and I
think people realize not just going to
be a quick fix
in the next month in the next two months
this is going to take some time and so I
don't know and when is it you know reach
a point where we are not going to play
you know you know this is August is in
July I still think the players when it's
LeBron James
especially those three teams at the
upper echelon the Lakers the Clippers in
the Bucs they all want to play no matter
what no matter if the season starts in
August or September the question is will
it be too late at that point yeah I'm
starting to wonder if we even have
basketball later on and as you're saying
June to August that's a pretty big
window there of going you know maybe and
then can you get fans to go back or you
shorten the season do you start the
playoffs right away I was told maybe you
do a best-of-three in the opening round
a best-of-five after that and then
best-of-seven after that like I guess
all ideas are on the table but I'm
starting to believe that we're not going
to have the NBA this season and one more
thing to really look at is the fact that
the NBA starting today I'm at our board
yesterday they're shutting down all the
practice facilities right so the players
are essentially quarantined all
quarantine at home don't have a choice
for the foreseeable future and how will
their game shape be you know between now
and let's say they have a two-month
layoff room you know we're in the same
period you know the country and as a
league where you can't do anything you
can't go in facility you can't go to a
public gym you know guys their
conditioning is going to take brought
about a handful of players express some
you know concerns about that with me as
well in terms of that you know this is
going to affect our game shape you know
are we going to be able to play when the
seasons back in July or August and we're
not in shape and so those are all things
that they're think about and I think
that everyone wants basketball there's
no question about it
it's a matter of doing it safely and I
don't know how that's going to be it's
going to be doing these games in G
League arenas in the practice Saudis is
it you know that they're going to come
up with something creative if this does
go on in July or August yeah how do you
think history is going to treat Rudy
Gobert you know I thought about this a
lot
over the last week since last Wednesday
I think
there's no question I think he would
even admit and he has admit that there
was some carelessness and you know some
recklessness in the way he cuts the mics
that previous you know couple days prior
on on that Monday and just his behavior
over the two days in terms of not fully
understanding the veracity of the
situation but I think I think obviously
he knows it now I think the whole
country knows it now I think the NBA
clearly has been at the forefront of it
and Adam silver clearly has put his foot
down and when the first pro league to
suspend in America and you know
everyone's kind of followed that same
same thing template ever since and so I
think he's gonna be that first guy that
tested positive and started to chain
chain events and not only pro sports I
think in America I think that was a
glaring moment across the whole country
and so someone had to be the first one
he was the first one and as you're
seeing now this wasn't just all related
to him this wasn't just one search has
made to be or this virus this is
reaching every sector of the NBA and
it's only likely going to increase
chomps thank you great job on breaking
those stories we appreciate your time
and we'll be following you writing for
the athletic that some Saranya